[Music]  president obama's reelection campaign is  having trouble settling on a new slogan  you know they haven't found anything as  effective as 2008 change you can believe  in now you can tell from recent speeches  that the president's been trying out new  slogans and he's had mixed results take  a look the american people understand is  required to win the future i laid out a  blueprint for an economy that is built  to last  philosophy is simple we are better off  when everybody is left to fend for  themselves i want to be clear this plan  like the other actions we've taken will  not help the neighbors down the street  that wasn't born in this country but a  debt that has grown over the last decade  primarily as a result of two years two  massive tax cuts and an unprecedented  financial crisis will have to be paid  now  [Applause]  we have trouble getting that on a bumper  stea